وصل شابان جزائريا الى مكه المكرمه
بالسعوديه علمتني دراجه ناريه بعد ان
انطلقا من الجزائر قبل حوالي شهرين لاداء
مناسك العمره وكشف ان رحلتهما استغرق
استغرقت 50 يوما وقطعا من خلالها 8 دول
تونس وليبيا قبل ان يعبرات الى تركيا في
رحله بحريه ويواصل رحلتهم الى العراق
وسوريا ولبنان وصولا الى الاردن وبعدها
السعوديه
[موسيقى]
مين يوم يا شيخ الله يبارك ما شاء الله
شوف الهمه شوف الهمه ما شاء الله اجو على
تونس ليبيا
تركيا لبنان سوريا حركه واحده قام بها دون
ان ينتبه خلال مباراه منتخب بلاده
الافتتاحيه في كاس العالم كانت كفيله بان
تجعل عبد الرحمن بن فهد بن جاسم ال ثاني
نجما على مواقع التواصل اجتماعي لمقطع
فيديو ايام تتجاوز مدته اربع ثواني
ظهر خلاله وهو منفعل خلال تشجيع منتخب
بلاده امام الاكوادور بكاس العالم فظهر
وكانه كاس العالم التي يطلق عليها اسم
لاعب وبسبب التشابه اصبح شاب واسع الشهره
وصار ايقونه في الصين واليابان كما لقب
بامير الحزين
[موسيقى]
في ظاهره غريبه لم يتم ايجاد تفسيرا واضح
لها حتى اليوم
ظهر مقطع فيديو قطيعا من الاغنام في جنوب
الاردن تدور حول نفسها في حادثه شبيهه لم
شهدته الصين حيث راحه قطيع من الاغنام
يدور حول نفسه بلا توقف لحوالي اسبوعين
فيما لم يزالوا سبب دوران الاغنام حول
نفسها غامضا رغم محاولات المتخصصين لتفسير
تلك الظاهره المثيره والغريبه
[موسيقى]
دنيا